not dance moves it's like whole routines
saw hope I'm Reese attila
and i'm taylor hatela Shane Bruce I'm a
professional dancer I've been dancing
for about 20 years now I'm Kayla Gaskin
I'm over 18 so we both started when we
were three years old my mom put me in a
dance class right then I don't know with
it like we both ended up quitting
gymnastics and just kind of holding with
dance classes and competitions I put out
a video - Nicki Minaj's anaconda and
then after her video kinda went viral
we started to dance together and then we
started to get known as that hotel
assisters I was the last of us before
tonight challenge video I think it's
gonna be easy I had no idea about it so
now that I'm back
I'm ready they're kids you can just pick
things up like that same industry longer
than we have I'm nervous like really
it's all shoot us out yeah yeah I'm
excited
it'll be fun
[Music]
[Music]
it's definitely not her she gives me the
energy
[Music]
[Music]
the electric I don't think I did the
same exact name but I got some like it
get funky okay
I played my dad and a party
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my feelings
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh I'm so ready I'm so ready or it's
justice we go boys you can go wait
[Music]
it won't be the same with all the
glitter that
[Music]
[Music]
one of the light over the art really hot
yeah I think any better than last time
whatever you guys went together you guys
go far we did Kritika no overall how do
you create a more confident yeah we did
solid good I can't absorb the moves that
good you guys picked it up like that